so we talked at the beginning of the
show we had this crazy weekend including
uh the biggest stock decline of the year
on Friday due to the fears and panic
over the Omicron variant as I already
said we don't yet know a long list of
important things that we at some point
will know about the Omicron variant but
needless to say it caused panic and
sell-offs in the stock markets it also
created an environment over the weekend
on right-wing media for an even bigger
scale up of covet and vaccine
disinformation now you might be saying
well hold on how could there be more
disinformation on covet and on vaccines
they've been doing it for close to two
years it's still getting even worse it
continues to get worse and worse and I'm
going to go through a couple of these
instances with you and we'll talk about
some of the the points that are being
made now in the context of Omicron
Republican Congresswoman Nancy mace was
interviewed on Fox News and her idea was
hey you know what maybe instead of
vaccine means people should get sick
with covid because you are better
protected this is something they've been
saying for a while take a listen to this
and see if you can figure out why it's
dangerously irresponsible as in one of
the things the CDC has not done and no
no policy maker at the federal level has
done so far is taken into account what
natural immunity does and that may be
what we're seeing in Florida today in
some studies that I've read natural
immunity gives you 27 times more
protection against future covid
infection than a vaccination and so we
need to take all of the science into
account now 20 she says 27 times I
haven't even been able to find a study
that asserts that I found one study that
says recent recovery gives you 27
percent better protection than the
vaccines which are tailored to the
original variants the best is still
recovery plus vaccine and remember the
vaccine won't kill you whereas getting
coveted to end up with immunity might
actually kill you selectively choosing
what science to follow when we are
making policy decisions and you're
seeing I believe Governor DeSantis is uh
you know seeing the fruit of that labor
today okay yeah the sand this has
actually done everything wrong on covid
but again even if it were true that
you're more robustly immune by
recovering rather than getting
vaccinated the process of recovering
naturally can kill you at close to a one
percent rate whereas what we know about
the vaccines is there are three people
who died from myocarditis
after being vaccinated it may have been
related and there have been hundreds of
millions of people in the U.S vaccinated
already so it's incredibly irresponsible
to say
for Jesus it's 27x even if it's 27 that
go through a process through which
nearly one percent will die to get
immunity rather than getting a shot very
very irresponsible and then lastly
recovered or not there's sort of like a
a game theory there's an optimal
solution
um to this which is
if you haven't recovered from the virus
you want to get the vaccine to develop
immunity if you have recovered from the
virus you get the vaccine and you get
even better immunity so either way you
get better immunity when vaccinated
incredibly irresponsible and dangerous
comments from Nancy mace then we go to
Donald Trump Jr
Donald Trump Jr is saying two things
which are crazy one is that nobody's
talking about the violent protests riots
anti-vaccine around the world that's
wrong I did an entire segment about it
last week it is being discussed and
number two he seems to think that we
should be having that here in the United
States go left so you don't hear about
these policies you know you you don't
hear about what's going on as it relates
to the riots in Europe on a daily basis
now against the vaccine mandates because
our media wants to block that out
they're going to make sure that you
never hear about it because they don't
want you getting these kind of ideas
that freedom may actually still exist in
some parts of the world I mean Europe is
pushing back and America's sitting there
like sheep uh you know this is great
we'll just go along think about what
he's saying he's saying they're he's
saying riots are good remember in other
contexts riots are bad and they can be
used to justify shooting people taking
out guns police being harsh with
protesters unless the rioters or
trumpists in which case it wasn't a ride
at all it was antifa and peaceful
but here he's saying there's riots going
on in Europe against the vaccines and
those are good and the media isn't
telling Americans about them because
Americans might realize hey we should do
that here and he says that would be a
good thing he thinks there should be
riots it would be good to have riots
here in the U.S
um next Lara Logan was on Fox News and
she I mean see if you can find the
number of lies in this statement and
again this is all the context is
reporting about Omicron Alias if you
look at Sweden with no lockdowns and no
vaccinations and look at the death rate
there over time what they're realizing
is they can't okay so there are it's
nine seconds guys and she's lying to you
three times first of all no lockdowns in
Sweden in Sweden without making it
policy of the state you had the sort of
Sheltering or separation
voluntary of uh the most vulnerable
swedes that's number one but it is true
that bars stayed open and okay that that
is true she says there's no vaccinations
in Sweden Sweden has more people
vaccinated than the US by percentage
right in the U.S we're at 59 fully
vaccinated in Sweden they're at 68 fully
vaccinated she's lying she said no
vaccines in Sweden reality more vaccines
in Sweden than the in the United States
and she says look at the death rate the
death rate in Sweden has started to
creep up creep up creep up and it's not
looking good in Sweden anymore it's a
very strange idealization of Sweden
based on lies we'll get back to Lara
Logan here's Stephen Miller former Trump
advisor who says you know if Trump were
in office we would already have modified
vaccines to deal with the new variants
which isn't true I mean just listen to
what the pharmaceutical companies are
telling us
president Trump was still in office by
the way we'd already have modified
vaccines to deal with the new variants
which is a great Point president Trump
bought us brought us vaccines in Record
Times which he made voluntary
non-mandatory and he'd have updates too
okay there is no evidence whatsoever
that we would already have modified
vaccines for the variants at this time
if Trump were president and the most you
know the funniest part of it is I guess
now vaccines are good again right when
you can attach them to accomplishments
of trump or imaginary accomplishments of
trump the vaccines are good other times
they placate to the most radical
anti-vax people uh on the Trump side
um here's an interesting one here's a
fox guest who the the discussion is
Omicron and he is able to use this to
talk about non-existent voter fraud in
the last election how do I don't know
how they managed to do it but they do
okay
um the benefit of of covet for the
Democrat Party they won the last
election action based on cobit they're
able to change election rules so it made
it far easier to cheat and potentially
steal you know different uh portions of
the electorate in the last election
was stolen hold on a second so hold on
do I do I think there was cheating in my
state of Wisconsin hell yes there was
cheating um that would have been a
change results I don't know you don't
know or you know because I didn't say I
didn't say it changed the election
results I said we'll fight about this in
the break he kind of just did he said I
don't know if it would have changed the
election results and of course there was
no evidence that anecdotal all the
things that always happen when 160
million people vote uh would have
changed the results in even a single
County never mind a single state so
making taking the Omicron opportunity to
talk about the big lie and then this is
completely off the rails we're going
back to Lara Logan
who has gone off the deep end
politically
she tells a story about how
there are Corona hundreds of
coronaviruses in Bones which is related
to her having bone cancer which isn't
funny but it's not even clear what
argument she's trying to make and
basically saying don't even try to
sequence variants like it's just it's a
crazy crazy thing and you can see the
doctor on the right side of the screen
starts to look a little bit confused
judge if they by the way that doctor's
the one who I guess talked to Trump
about his cognitive test he's a wacky
doctor and even he finds this nuts
testing for different strains of
coronavirus we're going to be locked
down for the rest of our existence I am
you know I had cancer my oncologist is a
specialist in bone cancer and he you
know every oncologist who deals with
bone cancer identifies hundreds of
coronaviruses inside of our bones
they've created a problem that can never
actually be solved so they can justify
whatever it is they want to do and if
you look around you everything is
falling apart even the the vote audits
are going ahead Durham is moving ahead
over time people can see that the
vaccines have nothing to do with Trump
or left or right many black people don't
want to get vaccinated you cannot
justify by the way that's being repeated
but it is not black folks who have the
lowest vaccination rate it's Trump
Republicans losing three to five
thousand border
potato flu and even and of course it's
not the death rate of flu it's about six
times that flu death rate is about 0.15
covet death rate is somewhere between
0.7 and 0.8 so that's very much untrue
this is lethal Americans have the right
under the Constitution to their civil
liberties and they can only be suspended
temporarily and for it to be looking
this is not let me totally and
completely Bonkers now the one thing
that is true about coronaviruses and
Bones is that covid can affect bone
growth in people who have not reached
their uh full size so to speak and can
affect bone density there are studies
about that so it seems getting covered
is potentially really bad for the bones
and we'll we're still learning more
about that so how long is this stuff
going to go on because at every time
that there's something new with the
pandemic they go back to the same things
the vaccines are probably not so so good
guidelines are definitely bad Trump
would have done everything better and
somehow with with some cases it's let's
go back to the the voter fraud that they
claim stole the election from Trump
in 2020. it's the same Playbook just
getting recycled over and over again
truly living in a fantasy world